hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book three of cicero's on the ends
cato the stoic philosopher is arguing
for what we can call the absolute
primacy of virtue what this means is
that he's saying that virtue is really
the good the thing that is good for us
as human beings and everything else if
it has any value at all it's reflected
or derivative from that of virtue so
nothing else really has intrinsic
positive value there is something else
that has intrinsic negative value and
that would be the opposite of virtue or
moral vice and the way in which they're
using virtue is both generic in the
sense of you might call it capital V
virtue which is essentially synonymous
here with moral goodness or moral value
the whole nessam in latin and/or
rectitude in own right rectitude oh and
also in the more specific sense of
virtues particular states of character
or personality that have been developed
within a human being we're going to talk
about those shortly the first thing that
I want to bring up though in talking
about this stoic conception of virtue is
you might say the big elephant in the
room aren't the Stoics really saying the
same thing as one of the other main
schools of virtue ethics at the time the
Peripatetic s-- or Aristotelian and this
is a live issue of contention within the
discussion happening in this book Cato
says definitely not Cicero says I think
it is the case you and the Stoics and
the Peripatetic soar Aristotelian are
just changing the words you're talking
about the same thing you're actually on
as we say the same page but don't
realize it and Cato says that is
definitely not the case so let's see
what Cato's argument is the Aristotelian
Xin his view say that virtue is a good
thing insofar as they say that they
agree with the Stoics
however the Aristotelian don't say
virtue is the only good thing or the
thing that makes all other goods good
rather they say well there's a lot of
different good things
Aristotle comes right out and says this
pleasure is something good it's not the
good the way that Epicureans or other
hedonist would say but it's it's good
it's just not as good as virtue virtue
is better than bodily pleasure or even
bodily health for that matter definitely
better than wealth definitely better
than social prestige or honor but all
those things are in fact good things
they're just lesser Goods they're not as
good as the capital G good which is
virtuous activity so the Aristotelian
Tsar willing to recognize a whole range
of goods the Stoics say that's not the
case
virtue is the only good the sole good or
if you don't like the word virtue say
moral rightness or intrinsic value all
right that's the sole good all other
things in that case are not really good
wealth is not a good it's not something
bad but it's not a good pleasure feels
good but it's not a good pain likewise
its opposite feels bad but it's not
something bad and we can say the same
thing about health we can say the same
thing about longevity of life we can say
the same thing about social prestige
celebrity contacts you name it social
media status whatever ranking you have
in some sort of database all of those
things are you might say extraneous to
the good they are not the good itself
they could
conducive to the good they could help
you make that good more active you could
say so if you're a virtuous person and
you do in fact have wealth and you can
use that wealth to do beneficent actions
that's kind of good but the wealth
itself is not something good neither is
the pleasure that results from it
neither is the honor only the virtue is
good so four key though there's a
fundamental difference between the
Aristotelian and stomach positions and
the Stoics are taking a very hard line
on this so let's talk for a minute about
what this encompasses I've used this
term virtue quite a lot so you know
that's the one that they start out with
but you notice if you read the text that
they are jumping between virtue and
moral goodness or the good or the end or
the highest good or any of these other
sort of synonyms and the goodness that
they're talking about there is the ho
nessam it's a word that we get honest
from it means something that is
intrinsically valuable it's not valuable
solely because it's useful or because
it's pleasant it is it is good in itself
sometimes it'll use rectal or rectum or
other things or rectitude it you know
those sorts of compositions that means
it's sort of straightness that's the
original meaning of recta right or
rectum means straight not bent going the
right way and that's a synonym for the
the hoenn a stub the morally good the
other thing that we do have to talk
about is okay so if virtue is the only
good what about our actions and choices
our actions and choices insofar as they
are indeed virtuous are good and they're
just as good as any other good actions
this is something that's really
distinctive to the stoic position when
you do a virtuous action that we think
of as kind of a small thing it is
as good as a virtuous action carried out
by somebody who has a lot of power or
money or you know is very successful in
doing that action and it effects all
sorts of other people you know Cato says
there's some actions that are bad no
matter what you're doing whether it has
good effects or not though those are
stemming from Vice likewise there some
actions that are good no matter whether
they're successful or not they are good
just by initiating them and the goodness
is there at the very beginning of that
action so this is a very strong as we
say de ontological point of view on the
goodness of actions but virtue is what
provides us with the index for that so
virtues and vices are our primary
criterion so we should talk for a minute
well what virtues does he have in mind
the Stoics looked to the four cardinal
virtues that had already been discussed
by Plato and by the time that all of
this moral reflection is coming on the
scene these are recognized as sort of
criteria or hallmarks of the good person
wisdom sometimes you'll see it
translated also as prudence wisdom is
the proper state of our mind it's been
fully developed if you know our natural
human propensity zand tendencies towards
seeking out truth and understanding of
things are engaged and we can figure out
what is actually good for us as human
beings and not just in a general sense
but think about how to deal with the
particular specific life circumstances
and choices that we have to make how do
we prioritize things among each other
justice giving everybody what is their
due that is a key part of this making
good on obligations and promises that we
have engaged ourselves in doing our
duties to other people but
for the Stoics also includes kindness
beginning the itas in in Latin
generosity been a benevolence and
beneficence
so that is a key part of it courage
being able not just to stand up against
fear but to resist the other emotions
like desire or anger and get the job
done that needs to get done through
difficult circumstances
temperance self-control particularly
with respect to bodily appetites the
desires for physical pleasures the
desires to avoid pain temperance is an
integral part of that so that gives us a
little bit more understanding of that
the other thing to mention too is that
he's going to bring up happiness
beatitude o or Beata vide Vita the happy
life the good life and for the Stoics
happiness comprises and includes
everything that is intrinsically
valuable everything that is good so in
order to be happy you would actually
need to have the virtues and there's one
point we're going to discuss a little
bit later where Cato says even if you're
making progress towards the virtues
you're just as miserable as everybody
else who isn't because you haven't
attained that that final point of
genuine happiness but the stoic slept
that the only thing that will in fact
make us really happy not just a
facsimile of happiness is being in in
line with the moral good now there are
some arguments that he provides and he
says that we can look at each of these
these are in rather still logistic form
so we can look at these very quickly the
first is that whatever is good is
praiseworthy but whatever is
praiseworthy is morally honorable as
honesta
therefore that which is good is morally
honorable whatever is good is going to
be the whole nest of in that case now
you could you could quibble with some of
the premises to this but if you accept
those premises you wind up at that
conclusion and he says that the usual
line of reply
to deny the major premise and say not
everything good is praiseworthy for
there's no denying that what is
praiseworthy is morally honorable but he
says this isn't actually going to work
then he brings up another really
interesting argument who can be proud
who can glory in a life that is
miserable or not happy it says one can
only be proud of one's lot when it's a
happy one so this proves the happy life
is a thing that deserves that one should
be proud of it and he says what can you
actually be proud of well only what's
morally honorable now again you might
reject some of these premises and I
haven't imagined that many people that
he has in mind would in fact reject
these but he would say they're wrong to
reject those and you could provide other
arguments for that he also gives us
another one about courage he says could
it be denied it's impossible for there
ever to exist a person of steadfast firm
and lofty mind a person we call a brave
one unless it be established that pain
is not an evil and what's the argument
there if you think that pain or death
really is something bad then you can't
help but not be courageous so if you
want to be courageous you have to
actually think that these things are not
genuinely bad the way they say the
Aristotelian would say but just
indifference things that you can face
probably not the best argument there the
last thing that he says that I think
it's particularly interesting and worth
keeping in mind the Stoics adopted a
position on virtue and the moral good
that they fully understood was
paradoxical what does it mean to be
paradoxical it means that people are
going to find this very counterintuitive
and have a hard time buying into it the
argument and they they provided actually
a number of sort of analogies and
arguments to support this is leading to
the conclusion that virtue the moral
good happiness these things do not have
increase or decrease they don't have
increase in the sense of growing they
don't have addition in the sense that
you could add anything to it and you
also can't decrease it or take anything
away from it so it doesn't matter
whether you're virtuous for a day and
then die immediately after that or
whether you're virtuous over the course
of 60 years it's the same moral value
it's the same happiness this does seem
rather paradoxical the Stoics would
express this through analogies like
saying you can drown just as well in an
inch of water as you can an entire ocean
or a puppy before it opens its eyes is
just as blind at that point as a blind
person later on there's argument after
argument after argument that they adduce
and this is a very tough position to
accept that there you know every single
virtue and every single virtuous act is
just as good as every other one likewise
every vicious act is just as bad as
every other one as well but if you
accept the stoic conception of these
things that is the conclusion that it
will lead you to so virtue for the
Stoics then and you might say moral
goodness because these are essentially
synonymous becomes the only thing that
should motivate us the only thing that
should be taken into account when we are
trying to figure out how to approach
what is going to make us happy what is
our final end or what is the greatest
good
you